When people go to the movies to see best friends
taking on incredible adventures, or beautiful
people sharing a passionate romance, they
don't usually stop to think if the actors
and actresses are actually as well matched
in person. And they definitely don't stop
to think if the cast absolutely hated sharing
the screen - but just managed to hide it.
You'd be surprised just how many of your favorite
stars, teams, or couples kept their actual
feelings behind the scenes, instead of in
front of the camera. Here are 10 Movie Casts
That Hated Working Together.
The Notebook
The romance between Noah and Allie became
a cultural phenomenon, but the actors were
a different story. From the moment Ryan Gosling
and Rachel McAdams met, they butted heads,
avoiding eachother outside of shooting, and
getting on eachother's nerves throughout the
movie's production. But it's proof that there's
a thin line between love and hate: the pair
eventually wound up dating for years, mirroring
the movie couple's dramatic romance more than
planned.
Mad Max: Fury Road
Actors don't have to hate eachother to have
trouble working together, and in the deserts
for months upon months, Charlize Theron had
a... difficult time getting to know her co-star
Tom Hardy. Since he stayed in character between
scenes, and she didn't, the tension only built
as the shoot dragged on. Theron has since
admitted that Hardy is apparently a great
actor to work with most of the time, but this
role was a different animal altogether - which
means their fight scene probably looks so
convincing for a reason.
Any GivenSunday
The movie may be remembered mainly for Al
Pacino's performance, but Oliver Stone's football
drama saw some real-life blows thrown between
rapper-turned actor LL Cool J and Oscar winner
Jamie Foxx. When LL decided to improvise,
giving his quarterback, Foxx, some shots to
his helmet, he gave him a fist in return,
and the two were off to the races. The police
were even involved, but the two decided to
get back to filming instead of pressing charges.
Romeo + Juliet
The love between Leonardo DiCaprio and his
Titanic co-star Kate Winslet is still going
strong, but the same can't be said for his
other famous love, the Juliet to his Romeo.
Despite being just 17 at the time, Claire
Danes couldn't stomach Leo's immature energy,
joking and breaking character between takes.
That meant their romance was even more faked
than usual, but you can't argue with the results.
The Basketball Diaries
They may be blockbuster names these days,
but when The Basketball Diaries was made,
Leonardo DiCaprio and Mark Wahlberg had yet
to kick their movie careers into high gear.
And after Leo felt that Wahlberg disrespected
him at a charity basketball game, he used
what little pull he had to try to get him
fired. Claiming there was no way he would
act in a movie beside "Marky Mark," he eventually
relented, and the two went on to bigger, better,
and less angry days.
Dirty Dancing
When actress Jennifer Grey burst onto the
scene as 'Baby,' it was her changing moods
and youthful giggles that won over fans - and
irritated her co-star. Patrick Swayze took
acting and dancing pretty seriously, and since
Dirty Dancing relied on both, Grey's inability
to stay in character, or keep serious apparently
strained his patience. He managed to keep
it off camera, or at least played it off as
the reaction of his character, not his own.
Batman Forever
Val Kilmer's Batman film may be laughed at
these days, but at the time, he was just one
of several stars in the cast, with Jim Carrey
at the height of his popularity playing Riddler
opposite Tommy Lee Jones' Two-Face. But when
Carrey sensed some tension from his fellow
villain, he found Jones at a restaurant near
the set to try to clear the air. Jones wanted
none of it, saying to Carrey's face: "I hate
you. I really don't like you. I cannot sanction
your buffoonery." Carrey didn't push him any
further.
Blade: Trinity
Wesley Snipes has a reputation for a reason,
and when he arrived on set, staying in character
as a vampire hunter was just the beginning.
Only appearing on set for close-ups, telling
his director to quit, and even choking him
before he brought in bikers for security united
the film's crew against him. But there was
a plus side: his absence gave Ryan Reynolds
a bigger role, specifically telling jokes
to play off of the deadpan close-up shots
that Snipes had filmed separately.
The Expendables 2
Sylvester Stallone's team-up franchise gave
a ton of aging action stars another adventure,
but judging by Bruce Willis' low energy and
refusal to say his famous Die Hard catchphrase,
he wasn't in it for the fun. Stallone confirmed
that was the case when Willis demanded $4
million to appear in the sequel - filming
for less than a week, and Stallone took his
feelings to Twitter. The pair eventually made
up, but his words of advice -GREEDY AND
LAZY ...... A SURE FORMULA FOR CAREER FAILURE
- will live forever.
Star Wars
You would think that actors Anthony Daniels
and Kenny Baker would have formed a bond squished
inside the droid bodies of C2PO and R2D2,
but the truth is, the two hated eachother
during production, and haven't changed since.
Over the years, Baker has accused Daniels
of avoiding most of the movie's cast and fan
base, and dismissing him as an actor and little
person, while Daniels mainly ignores it, but
has voiced his opinion that despite Baker's
performance operating R2, it might as well
have been a bucket. Who knew?
Those are just a few of our favorite off-screen
feuds or tense movie sets, but which ones
did we miss? Make sure you let us know your
own examples in the comments, and subscribe
to our channel for more videos like this one.